makeup is not your your jam
Tom Brady is [ __ ] fine I feel like
[Music]
do you guys know who Thomas Patrick
Edward Brady is that's yeah Tom Brady
yeah
so crazy like that sounds like a why are
you saying all crazy like that just give
me his name so he's a very famous NFL
quarterback yep would you say he's the
most famous NFL quarterback I would say
he's the most famous NFL quarterback is
he also considered wide Leaf the best
true I would say he's the best
quarterback yeah Tiger Woods would you
say also I've I have a debate with one
of my friends would you say he's the
most impressive champion in sports I
would say that yes because especially
because I respect football the most and
I think that most of the sports are
pretty much trash more than Michael
Jordan I love Michael Jordan bro he's an
icon forever for me but he only won six
how many is Tom wins seven oh so six is
in that game and he retired and then
came back yeah and then one with a
different team with a different team bro
and that's because that was the other
thing the other thing was like oh he's
the only one with Bill Belichick and
then he [ __ ] goes to Tampa Bay wins
with Bruce Arians who's also a great
coach but like different teams going to
Tampa Bay would you say that like they
weren't really a technically considered
a Powerhouse they weren't well they they
had really nice weapons but Jameis
Winston was not getting it done for them
he was throwing tons and tons and tons
of picks and so Tom Brady brought like
really good football to Tampa Bay for
sure was it more impressive to see Tom
Brady bring Tampa Championship or LeBron
go back to Cleveland and bring them a
Championship uh Brady okay for me only
because like I don't like I know that
like LeBron going back to Cleveland was
a big [ __ ] deal it was crazy but
watching Tom Brady leave the Patriots
after winning six with them was [ __ ]
wild and especially at that time with
all the legend of Bill Belichick all the
whipcraft like all the weapons yeah all
the [ __ ] the Championships when Tom
Brady went to Tampa for the first year
did he win a championship that first
year the first year
was it more impressive to see Tom Brady
go to Tampa with all that or watch
Michael Jackson Michael Jordan play
baseball for a little bit and then come
back to the Wizards and lose
that was more impressive
than watching Michael Jackson blow a kid
whoa that would have been crazy yeah
that's probably way crazier to see uh so
Tom and Giselle his supermodel wife
Gisele Bud chin
button she they're getting a divorce
that's what I heard yeah bro because
she's mad that they're like the hottest
couple ever they're like they're
probably the hottest couple ever yeah
more than Becca man [ __ ] sexy spice
or whatever the [ __ ] her name is you're
pretty hot I hear a lot of women that I
talk to don't think Tom Brady is that
good looking what who the [ __ ] oh the
only big guys are like what I think he's
been looking do you think he's good
looking that's nice I have this Tom
Brady or Beckham
Tom Brady oh wow oh you don't like
pretty boys I almost got a crush huh
back up back up is not your your jam
Brady is [ __ ] fine I feel like David
Beckham fine you know what I mean I mean
he's like fine but he's more of like oh
you kind of cute yeah yeah yeah Tom
Brady is like if I'm gonna make a
superhero [ __ ] figurine I'm like
what's my inspo oh [ __ ] like Tom
Brady I really Becca was like Calvin
Klein modeled wearing type fine though
right Brady said no I would put Tom
Brady he's also like a little you know
like in terms of athletes yeah but I
think athletes I'm like oh like how big
are you five eleven oh that's kind of
cool
name Beckham's like five four also I'd
much rather go to a football game Tom
Tom Brady is [ __ ] well I don't know
he's got to be like Galaxy yeah but like
Tom Brady though yeah Tom Brady football
is but the level of champion Tom Brady
is that's soccer like
he's 45 years old he won the Super Bowl
at 44 years old that's crazy or what was
it 43 is he the oldest quarterback to
win his Super Bowl I don't I don't know
I'm sure he's got some stats like that
Tom Brady winning with Tampa or Tiger
Woods coming back and win The Masters in
2019. dude that was awesome but it had
been a long time since tiger won right
and Tiger's ugly
wow
I think he's ugly yeah he's an ugly guy
man do you think Tiger Woods is ugly
clean oh
my God
I'll go I think he's a Pokemon yeah what
a [ __ ] matron I wouldn't say that
Megatron's cousin it's like a Chuck E
Cheese robot well yeah I don't think
Tiger Woods is Ugo I think he's neutral
neutral yeah he just looks so worried
all the time but does the does the
performance of athletes but that's not
attractive he doesn't look like he's
like confident man when athletes are
really really good at something do they
become better looking to you yep I think
just some people Tom Brady's glow up is
actually pretty good because if you like
posting some of his like old photos and
it's like yeah it's like he he's got a
glow up well dude his draft or what was
it the the NFL combine picture of him
like yeah I found my pictures legendary
for sure and he was what like considered
he was drafted as a backup quarterback
right at the time yeah he was backing up
uh Drew Bledsoe yeah that's right yeah
oh it's crazy they're gonna make a movie
out of this guy yeah he was like pick
whatever the [ __ ] hundred whatever and
then he he goes to back up Bledsoe he's
already a great quarterback considered
at the time greatest draft pick of all
time would you say Tom Brady I think you
have to say it at this point right it
breaks my [ __ ] heart to say it
achy breaky heart I used to argue Peyton
Manny's the greatest quarterback in NFL
I still think he's like right there with
Brady but man's the Championships speak
for themselves don't they does Tom Brady
have any like scandals this one I mean
this I mean this is getting a divorce is
kind of the [ __ ] American way though
oh what are you gonna say about that
people are scared this is how light it
is I think the only one was like he
kissed his son on the lips one time oh
yeah and the people freaked out he
should have been canceled but he's like
yeah I've been doing that since I was a
kid in a documentary yeah
just because his son's 18. yeah yeah
yeah he's been doing it since he was
like oh what about deflate game but
that's not really him right that's not
really him I mean well they they
actually find there well it was
considered him but I don't think it
really [ __ ] happened actually like I
think it was a bunch of [ __ ]
honestly and like I said I sound like a
big Brady fan right now I [ __ ] hate
Tom Brady but you have to respect the
man wow that's how good he is he's just
that good it's like below check what was
the reason for the divorce they just
literally just regular couldn't make the
marriage
so regular divorce they're saying it's
coming from giselle's side mostly but
that's we don't [ __ ] know but that's
what they're saying because she doesn't
want him to go back and play because he
retired as of last year right last year
but he wants to come back is that why he
came back already he's playing right now
dude he lost Monday Night Football last
week or what was Sunday Night Football
so he wants to come back and win another
maybe all his crypto projects didn't
work out he's like [ __ ] I gotta go back
and play right hey we've been there huh
we've been there that's why we're still
here baby we still here
I just wants him to be at home oh that
was that was fake that was fake
my [ __ ] dude eat my [ __ ] [ __ ] no but uh
so so last year he says hey I'm retiring
it was kind of weird everyone thought
was kind of odd because he says I'm
retiring and then he comes back like a
month and a half later and says like ah
yeah I'm not gonna retire after all I
think I I still belong out there and
then everyone started to say like the
retirement announcement initially was
weird people started to re-examine it
and go like how come you just came out
the way that he came out said he's
retired it seemed like maybe it was
leaked by giselle's size what people are
are wondering like maybe she like she's
like you're retiring and he's like I
don't know and then it was announced
that he was retiring if you guys
remember uh before he actually announced
it yeah it was really weird yeah and he
says that's not true I'm not retiring
and then everyone's like oh okay and
then the next day he actually says I am
retiring and gives like the full thing
everyone thought that was kind of odds
so it's like a leaked thing so then we
fast forward to training camp in August
Brady is told or Brady tells the press
and and and everybody that he had a
scheduled thing right so everybody's
like oh Brady has a thing and so he's
not going to be practicing with the team
which is [ __ ] weird for Tom Brady he
loves practice right he's a [ __ ]
weirdo he loves practice he loves
preparation all that [ __ ] that's why
he's a champion I guess well he's a
champion right but that but that's so
everyone thought that was really weird
right and then we're hearing now that
they just hired divorce attorneys so
we're like people were guessing back
then like something's going on with
Brady and he actually came when he came
back he was like he's like look I got a
lot of [ __ ] going on I'm 45 years old
right and so everyone's like all right
we'll chill but then now we're hearing
about divorce attorneys so maybe it was
it was like we think that there was some
kind of dust up back in August and now
it's all coming to a head
yeah it's crazy how much he's achieved
by 45. it's [ __ ] crazy you have even
more gangster it goes through a divorce
here and wins dude I think that's what
he wants that would be the most
incredible and then they get back
together and they're like that was great
press honey she goes I knew you were a
champion I knew you were gonna do it
only to motivate him to push him to
higher boundaries and now he's retiring
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll be so
honest dudes I I rooted for him in the
last Super Bowl when he was with Tampa
Bay because he wasn't a patriot anymore
so it was easier for me to do because
I'm a close fan on [ __ ] eighth
Patriots but yeah but it's Colts and
Patriots they're rivals or well they
don't consider us Rivals because they
step on us like we're [ __ ] ants
we're mad at the booth we're mad at the
boot yeah and we remember they don't
[ __ ] remember we just wait we'll
never forget are the Colts bad we're
horrible at football
why do you love cold so much I got
cursed with being born in Indianapolis
he's like I just like blue and white ah
okay that's my team dude that's it who's
there back right now
um his name is Matt Ryan and I mean is
he a quarterback or is he just a fumble
machine
did you say nine in the last two games
he's got more fumbles and receptions
dude he has 10 fumbles now in the last
five games oh [ __ ] got a fumble last
night fresh one oh Broncos right yeah
Broncos oh it's respect guys that come
from home teams that suck ass but they
stick to it because that's kind of like
David with Sacramento seems like he
watches basketball and Kings literally
had like one period where they were
crushing it yeah but before then they
were like giving away [ __ ] tickets to
go watch
crushed it for like a year or two and
then [ __ ] suck ass what was that was
that like my baby time yeah I used to
work downtown L.A and the day after
Colts lost the Super Bowl of the [ __ ]
Saints 2009
put on my [ __ ] Jersey and I went to
work because it was casual friend or
whatever or as a casual whatever day
because after Super Bowl we could wear
whatever the [ __ ] remember so I show up
with my Kohl's Jersey on I'm walking to
Gauntlet downtown L.A well you Colts
[ __ ] suck Peyton Manning blew it oh
yeah the [ __ ] [ __ ] you Tracy Porter
rocks
but I took it because that's my [ __ ]
team took that [ __ ] and you know what
they haven't even smell the Super Bowl
since then dude and honestly our team
our team is such a bunch of little
[ __ ] when's the last time they won
Super Bowl
um we won in 2006 2007 plus Julia
dressed like a saint right now I know
right I got the colors but no we are
just little [ __ ] [ __ ] that our
former GM's named Ryan Gregson he
complained and that's what started
deflategate when we lost AFC
Championship game it was like 47-0 yeah
and then Ryan Griggs and rgm like
tattled on on the on the Patriots to the
league and said like oh these balls were
like [ __ ] the PSI for whacking them
so that's what started the whole [ __ ]
thing so then they try to make Colts
fans look like [ __ ] we don't I didn't
even support that [ __ ] I thought that
was whack all right so I have one final
question of the record yeah if what do
you think the Colts need to be like
o-line dude our o-lines maybe like Tom
Brady we need Tom Brady they need Tony
Dungey back or what I love Tony Dungy
but there's no way he's coming back he's
getting paid [ __ ] well to just chill
in a booth on Sunday nights so no way
just outliner o-line is trash our online
so [ __ ] bad I can't believe it Matt
Ryan steps back he has like half a
second he gets trampled
and last year with Carson Wentz Carson
Wentz looks better everyone's [ __ ] all
over Carson Wentz for [ __ ] nine
months of Carson wins look better
because our o-line was the problem not
[ __ ] wins in my opinion what kind of
receivers you guys got we got Michael
Pittman Jr he's [ __ ] solid we got
um a guy named Paris Campbell because
glass knees
[Laughter]
do you know what you would do if Colts
won the Super Bowl how you would
celebrate what would I do if the Colts
won the Super Bowl again I'll tell you
what I would do because I'm so [ __ ]
pissed or what happened to me in 2007.
so in 2007 the Colts won the Super Bowl
can't [ __ ] believe it unbelievable
right well my improv team my stupid
[ __ ] Herald team had a show stupid
[ __ ] day and like nobody went to the
shows dude it's like a rainy night in La
nobody goes to the shows but we have a
show all the way in like West Hollywood
so they're like yo Steve are you coming
on The Coasters won the Super Bowl [ __ ]
all you guys and they're like you gotta
come like the show like we have a show
there's more people I go of course so I
don't get to watch the Colts like like
afterwards like raise the trophy and all
this [ __ ] like I I live I don't get to
watch that [ __ ] I just know we won the
Super Bowl and I got all my friends
while I was leaving and then I show up
there and there's more people on stage
than in the audience like four people in
the audience it was a rainy night I had
to pay for parking there's four people
on stage it was so bad dude and I was
just like pissed so this time I'd sit
there and [ __ ] watch them raise the
trolls soak it up huh yeah soak it up
plus that was the night Prince did
purple rain in the [ __ ] rain oh that
night that's
wrong it was incredible so I was glad I
got the water that's like top five Super
Bowl shows ever I was to me number one
ever no dude Purple Rain In The Rain
Michael Jackson still beats oh that was
sick well he when he just stood there
yeah for like five minutes yeah
he knew the whole world's watching him
he's just like yeah keep watching me and
kids watched a little lower
kids right down here nice down
[Music]